E aí
[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao diálogo sobre
pensamento Global em Ação local e não
poderíamos ter o melhor momento para
essa tipo de reflexão do que o momento
atual o momento de uma pandemia que se
espalhou rapidamente pelo mundo todo
acertando absolutamente cada país cada
cidade e cada um de nós de alguma forma
alguns mais outros menos mas todos foram
impactados todos conhecemos alguém que
ficou doente e precisou de ajuda que
está sofrendo a feito econômico que está
sofrendo a rede social de um isolamento
que continua já vários meses
É também um momento que mostra muito bem
como colaboração Global poderia avançar
de uma forma mais rápida a solução
e o exemplo disso é a campanha de
vacinação vacinas que foram rapidamente
elaboradas por várias entidades várias
empresas com a esforço de várias
especialistas pesquisadores que
colaboraram globalmente na sua
elaboração
e agora a pergunta é como que vamos
viver a reconstrução depois da pandemia
se vamos repetir os mesmos erros que nos
trouxeram para cá Porque a pandemia foi
anunciada aprender minha veio sendo
apontada por vários especialistas como
algo garantido acontecer no futuro e não
conseguimos nos preparar Então vamos
repetir o mesmo ou vamos reconstruir de
uma forma diferente Vamos retomar de uma
forma diferente as nossas atividades
econômicas e sociais Vamos pensar de uma
outra forma as políticas que nos possam
ajudar tanto prevenir Possivelmente
algumas dessas pandemias algumas dessas
crises sejam sanitária sejam sociais
seja militares sejam econômicas ou se
vamos pelo menos reduzir de alguma forma
a vulnerabilidade de várias parcelas da
sociedade aos possíveis acontecimentos
dessa natureza
a agenda 2030 como seus 17 objetivos de
desenvolvimento sustentável oferecem um
excelente Marco que poderia nos ajudar a
repensar como vivemos como fazemos
política que política que fazemos que
projetos que escolhemos para o nosso
investimento para que tivéssemos o mundo
um pouquinho pelo menos diferente
aprendendo das nossas erros das
incorporado lições aprendidas que
foram-nos oferecidas contra nossa
própria vontade durante o ano todo
a agenda é nada mais nada menos do que
uma ferramenta uma ferramenta de
planejamento uma ferramenta que nos
ajuda a escolher Como investir não
apenas escolher as temáticas mas também
a escolher a qualidade do nosso
investimento seja ele é público seja ele
privado
a primeira tentativa de se oferecer o
Marco dessas Não de jeito nenhum agenda
2030 foi construída acima de décadas de
aprendizado um dos resumos é o conceito
de desenvolvimento humano um conceito
que nasceu 30 anos atrás com base nos
pensamentos na literatura escrita por
amartya sen O Vencedor de prêmio Nobel
que trouxe para o nosso entendimento o
conceito de desmanche humano
desenvolvimento que incorpora Vertentes
de educação e saúde não embasa-se apenas
no crescimento econômico como base
e de outro lado também é temos o
conceito de desenvolvimento sustentável
um de um conceito que foi elaborado por
um painel de especialistas no contexto
das Nações Unidas e um conceito que
trouxe consigo também um grama grande
campanha de mobilização chamada Agenda
21 uma campanha de mobilização que
engajou múltiplos municípios múltiplas
organizações da sociedade civil e também
empresas no processo de pensamento no
processo de localização de compromisso
Global em prol de um ambiente preservado
em prol de preservar a nossa terra para
futuras gerações
E essas dois conceitos foram bastante
importantes e mudaram como nós
percebemos o processo de desenvolvimento
mas apenas essa mudança não foi
suficiente Então como como aprendizado
veio a proposta da declaração do milênio
um grande o compromisso dos governantes
globais para trabalharem para o
desenvolvimento e Vieram também os 8
objetivos de dez minutos do milênio com
metas indicadores com uma primeira
tentativa de oferecer Marco concreto não
apenas com 218 humano e conceito de
desenho sustentável com o indicador
medindo o progresso global que é o IDH
também o Marco que ajudaria Então os
governantes a fizerem é
as decisões informadas a fazerem
políticas e decisões de política pública
de forma que ataca os pontos mais
doloridos que ataca aquilo que poderia
levar então ao desmando humano mais
rápido das muito humano mais distribuído
pelo mundo todo
a agenda 2030 vem como uma continuidade
natural dessa primeira agenda dos
odeemes que existe iniciou Desde há dois
mil entrar no 2015 no finalzinho desse
período foi ocorreu a conferência Rio +
20 que analisou as lições aprendidas com
os 8 odms é e colocou as bases para a
construção da agenda 2030 e os 17
objetivos as metas ostentavam uma agenda
que não foi construída apenas por um
painel de especialistas mas foi
elaborada por meio de um processo de
consulta pública muito amplo uma agenda
que se aplica absoluta de todos os
países independentemente do seu status
na tabela do IDH é e também mais venda
que trás as preocupações na não apenas
sociais como os adms trouxeram mas
também as preocupações econômicas e
ambientais e
o que mais obriga a pensar de uma forma
holística e integrada uma forma que
considera que não dá para sacrificar
social a ambiental o econômico que se
precisamos fazer todo o esforço para
alcançar equilíbrio entre essas três
preocupações para preservação do nosso
planeta para casamento humano de outra
forma dizendo humano que previne que
preserva a nossa planeta terra para
futuras gerações e que ajuda se portanto
a reduzir o impacto negativo da ação
humana da ação humana que ficou tão
forte tão influente no nosso mundo que
estamos vivendo uma mudança de épocas
uma mudança para antropoceno uma época
geológica que se destaca pela
importância da são Nossa onde a
humanidade pode tanto oferecer A melhor
solução mas também o maior risco para a
nossa própria sobrevivência
o
e o interessante que é agenda 2030
apesar de ser bastante complexa e muito
amplo ela também foi muito mais abraçada
por exemplo do que os 8 odms eu lembro
em 2003 porque eu não quando foi a
primeira vez que o ouvido os ADM é era
um grande trabalho convencer as pessoas
informar informar as pessoas primeiro
sobre a sua existência porque ninguém
sabia e convencer que era algo
interessante assim engajar já agenda
2030 nós começamos com muitas pessoas
conhecendo muitas pessoas que já foram
engajados na sua construção muitas
pessoas que já ouviram muitas entidades
que abraçaram rapidamente não apenas
entidades da sociedade civil o
governante gestores públicos também as
empresas se engajaram bastante rápido em
todos os setores na sua implementação
o porquê que a gente ofereceu a foi tão
atraente mais do que os ADM Porque ela
foi construída de baixo para cima porque
houve consultas públicas porque ela é se
amplie trás todo tipo de preocupação e
ela se aplica a todos os países todas as
cidades e municípios bairros e casas
como um colega meu diz agenda é agenda
tanto para presidente de um país quando
para pai ou mãe de uma família e todos
nós temos o que é contribuir todo cada
um de nós podemos pensar individualmente
que que eu mudo na minha rotina diária
como também pensar no no espaço de
trabalho como que eu mudo meu jeito de
trabalhar como que eu mudo o conteúdo do
meu trabalho que que eu posso agregar a
a minha atuação que pudesse trabalhar
maior resiliência que possa ser melhor
alinhado às preocupações da agenda 2030
os 17 horas
o quanto até o nível de investimentos
Grandes Empresas e políticas públicas
nacionais
bom então encorajo cada um de nós aqui
refletir Como que eu posso contribuir
porque contribuindo com a agenda 2030 e
17 S eu não apenas vou contribuir com a
implementação de um Marco Global eu de
fato vou ajudar meu país a ser
reconstruído depois da pandemia convide
de uma outra forma de uma forma que é
mais sustentável socialmente e
ambientalmente e econômica
economicamente e que ajuda a reduzir
Impacto de ação humana que ajuda a
repensar a atuação de outra forma de uma
forma que possa pra preservar o nosso
planeta Terra se para as futuras
gerações
e eu desejo um bom trabalho cada um
desejo bons debates no contexto dessa
evento dessa série de de falas que vocês
vão ouvir e desejo que com cada ideia
que será compartilhada seja incentivada
a nossa criatividade seja incentivada o
nosso compromisso para se pensar global
e agir local dentro das nossas casas
dentro das nossas empresas Ou então
repartições públicas